Брехня та дезінформація переповнили інтернет.
Як орієнтуватися, правдива новина чи ні? Ось три поради, як розпізнати фейкові дописи.
На цьому відео показано, як ракета наче врізається в Місяць.
А на цьому ми нібито бачимо космічний корабель, який руйнує Червону площу в Москві.
Тут російський уряд стверджує, що кадри з тілами, які лежали на вулицях Бучі,
були "інсценовані" після відходу російських військ з Київщини.
Це все приклади фейкових новин. У соцмережах відео чи статті, які дезінформують,
поширюють в шість разів швидше, ніж точні новини.
Будь-кому, хто користується Інтернетом, час усвідомити, що це величезна проблема.
Ось три поради, як відокремлювати правду від брехні в інтернеті.
Перш за все, сумнівайтесь. Велика ймовірність, що ви зіткнетеся з фейками в мережі.
Фактчекер DW Йоша Вебер зазначає, що нам, як ніколи, слід бути обережними.
Будьте обережні, якщо натрапите на емоційні чи суперечливі теми в інтернеті.
Або якщо заголовок заявляє про сенсацію.
Загалом такі емоції, як гнів або страх, змушують нас легше вірити в неправдиві історії.
Коротше кажучи: якщо щось занадто добре, щоб бути правдою, то це, вірогідно, фейк.
Тому залишайтеся скептичними.
Наприклад, подивіться на цю світлину пари, яка нібито спостерігає за запуском ракети "Аполлон-8".
Як ми з’ясували під час пошуку в Інтернеті, фотографія була підроблена.
Цим відео Володимира Путіна також зманіпулювали.
Нібито він оголошує, що Росія капітулювала у війні проти України - однак це діпфейк.
На відео наклали змонтовану звукову доріжку.
По-друге, запитайте себе: хто стоїть за статтею або відео, які ви бачите?
Коли інформація потрапляє до вас через соціальні мережі чи месенджери,
одразу шукайте відповідь на запитання: хто поширює цю інформацію,
якою може бути мета та наскільки надійне джерело?
Щоб пролити світло на контент, який ви щойно спожили - перевірте обліковий запис автора допису.
Наприклад, якщо обліковий запис має мало підписників і відносно новий,
але регулярно публікує дописи, це може вказувати на бота, який поширює дезінформацію.
Часто буває й так, що людина отримує від когось новини і пересилає їх без попередньої перевірки.
Багато платформ зараз вказують, чи було переслане повідомлення чи ні.
Наприклад, WhatsApp показує маленьку стрілку над повідомленням, щоб вказати, що його переслали.
А дві стрілки означають, що повідомлення пройшло через принаймні п’ять чатів.
Якщо в публікації або повідомленні є посилання, ви можете натиснути на нього, щоб перевірити, куди воно веде.
Однак сама наявність посилання, не означає, що воно активне або є свідченням правдивої новини.
Коли ви переходите за лінком, то може виявитися, що ви потрапили на політичний сайт,
приватний блог чи навіть сайт сатири.
Ознаки ненадійних новинних вебсайтів наступні: відсутність юридичних застережень, текстові помилки,
непрофесійний дизайн сайту або якщо вам пропонують не тільки інформацію, але й щось придбати.
Наша третя порада: якщо новина здається вам дивною, спробуйте перевірити її.
Наприклад: у березні 2022 року сотні користувачів соціальних мереж стверджували,
що гендиректора "Діснея" Боба Чапека заарештували за торгівлю людьми.
Це був фейк. Один із способів перевірити таку новину - подивитися, чи розповсюджують її надійні ЗМІ,
і чи коментують офіційні органи.
У цьому випадку простий запит у пошуку показує, що новина неправдива.
Сайти з фактчекінгу також спростовують твердження.
Для інших новин ви можете перевірити першоджерела, на які посилаються в дописі,
такі як дослідження, програми політичних партій або публічні виступи.
Отже, підсумуймо три найважливіші поради щодо того, як розпізнати фейк:
По-перше, запитайте себе: чи звертається твердження в новині до емоцій чи базових інстинктів?
По-друге, перевірте першоджерело!
І по-третє, перевірте вміст та ознайомтеся з додатковою інформацією з авторитетних ЗМІ та вебсайтів!
І головне, не ставайте частиною машини дезінформації.
Якщо ви не впевнені, що твердження правдиве, не поширюйте його!